nous sommes en l'an 680 dans ce petit
fort au quai du mont royal
les sulpiciens plante le premier
vignoble de montréal pour faire leurs
vannes s est même si les champs ou
disparus lavigne trouve encore sa place
entre les gratte ciel du centre ville
c'est elle qui a fait germer l'idée il y
a trois ans sur le toit du palais des
congrès c'est une façon très économique
est super belle pour végétaliser la
ville différemment puis une capture de
carbone aussi super intéressante les
toits d'ubisoft de l'institut de
tourisme et d'hôtellerie et de la
centrale agricoles ont emboîté le pas la
saq partenaires de l'opération elle
aussi sa parcelle de vigne en ville qui
est d'abord une expérience de recherche
d'assez expérimentation leurs membres
qui remplace en fait le sable à
l'intérieur des terreaux et l'autre
chose vous avez peut-être vu donc il n'y
pas y voir également dans le pays va
permettre une réverbération sur les
plants de vigne quant aux températures
caniculaires de l'été c'est plutôt un
avantage sur un jour ici on enregistre
souvent de 50° l'on en fait donc il n'y
a absolument rien qui survit au sol donc
on n'a pas cette pression dans le fond à
des mallettes pas de maladies peu de
traitements et des vendanges hâtives et
c'est probablement la première vendange
la première vendange du québec
en tout à montréal 375 pieds sont
plantés mais seules quelques dizaines
vont pouvoir donner du vin cette année
ces compléments pionniers ce qu'on fait
on est quand même beau plein coeur de
montréal c'est super cool d'être
encerclés tous les bâtiments qui des
trains est en train de faire les
vendanges
véronique lemieux pense pouvoir produire
une centaine de bouteilles que la saq
n'exclut pas de mettre en vente
après oui on s'attend pas à faire un
grand cru mais notre première cuvée
expérimental
en neuf vinifié à l'automne dernier nous
ont réservé quand même des belles
surprises avec les services d'un
monologue et d'un vinificateur triage
des raisons foulage au pied et première
extraction du jus montréal si mathieu
prostré du canada montréal